Emily what's going on at the moment and
do you think we might see you again in
another Inbetweeners movie the sequel I
don't know what's happening with me now
I've just shot a pilot for an American
channel so we'll wait and see if that
gets picked up a secret I don't know I
was really mean to Simon so if there is
a sequel I don't even know if he'd be
remotely interested in Carly anymore she
was like building yourself up to be like
that every day it was a gradual process
when the series first started she was a
very sweet girl next door and just
throughout the years bitterness I think
of the writers previous relationships
just shown through college so yeah I
kind of didn't realize that it happened
until fans kept going out to me going
you're really mean you really mean to
sign assignment an idiot to be fair he
does stupid things so you know Carly's
well within her right to think that he's
a bit of a fool but hopefully you know
if you if maybe if you've got nicer or
maybe if you got less stupid we could
see you in the sequel it may be in
Australia they're talking about oh
really why I don't know much about what
they're discussing or whether it's all
you know press hearing things on the
grapevine but yeah maybe maybe Carly
could become nice I don't know I think
she's kind of just buried herself a bit
I think I've you've got an Australian
cousin Marlene to him he's really lovely
I'm not grateful thanks baby doesn't
like Emily
you